好,谢谢大家,然后我觉得上一周市场最主要的就是那个美联储的会议
然后我今天其实想,我看到网上有各种说法吧,就是那个Kevin Wash为什么这么硬派
然后大流大致的说法是这样子,就是觉得那个美联储现在变得更加硬派一点的
然后让市场觉得它能够控制通章,然后控制通章要把那个长端利率砸下来一些
使得这个美国融资产门变低,因为整个政府的债务看上去不算sustainable,不是可持续的
然后我个人有一些不同的看法,就是对于那个美联储的政策
然后我觉得今天我想,因为说半导体来说的话,讲了好几个星期了
我觉得大致的方向还是我上两周讲的这个方向,我等会过一下
接下去7月份,就是7月份要出二纪录的季报,然后我觉得二纪录季报的时候
要注意些什么东西,然后我觉得今天我想说一下美联储和美国货币政策
然后特别是我对长端利率的一个看法,就是5年10年吧,那个利率的一个看法
然后和对美国这个美元还有这个美债这个地位的一个看法
然后我首先把它认同,之前我刚刚讲的,就是Fed变得更加硬派,其实是对于通胀的控制
然后希望这个长端利率下来,那么当然市场短期里面是这么交易的
因为先回顾一下美联储的决定,美联储利率没有变
但是它最主要的两个,一个是减少了communication,减少了这个沟通
然后呢,第二个呢,就是不给那个相对不给Fed out了,不给那个预计,它是想把利率交给市场
所以一面发的呢,就是短端长了很多,短端的利率上了很多,如果整个cov在flat
然后我觉得包括长期交易的方向对于长端利率的看法,我都是跟很多人相反
我觉得长端利率要在这个时点往后,在一个比较长的周期里面,应该是往上跑,而不是往下跑
然后整个利率应该变得steep,就是变得更到,tempremia变高,而不是变低
所以这个是我个人的看法,所以我说一下我整个的逻辑,包括我对联储为什么要做这件事情的一个个人的看法
首先我引误一个概念,就是你的利率,是不是美国的利率没有办法维持在现在这个位置
其实对于美元或者是维持在这个位置的利率太高,债务扩展以后会不会影响美元地位
首先我觉得这是不会的,就是你在美元不管在什么样的利率上,然后不管美元借了多少债,都不太会去影响美元的地位
因为美元地位本质上是美国是全世界最大的一个债务交易市场
也就是说他欠债欠人多,是他这个债务的流动性更好,他就变成一个储位
他的储位的地位是由债务的归过来的,就是他深度很高,是这么来的
然后第二呢,他的这个美元储位的地位取决于美元美国的法律,就也不是他的军事吧
就主要是全世界金融底层的法律,就是你原代码是人家英语写的,人家暗利法写的
这个原代码是美元,你是不可能取代他的,这个事情我们之前讲过好多次
包括你看所有的抵押品啊,CICA抵押品啊,包括结算啊,都是这么原来做
所以你很难有任何一个货币取代他储备货币的地位,那么在这种情况下呢
他这个发债就是,其实想发多少就发多少,所以不会去影响这个东西
但是我觉得特别是这一届共和党政府,对于对于这个国进民进国退这件事情是比较敏感
也就是如果说我引入一个RG的概念,R就是利率,G就是增长,如果当你的
利率高于增长的时候,你的债务会无限扩展
我就是以前那个BuGlox好像讲过一个怪太年叫快乐supernova,就是那个
债务的
债务的那个红巨星,债务的超巨星
所以当你的利率高于你的增长的时候,其实你发生了三件事情
第一个呢,就是你挤压了public debt,就是公共的债权,挤压了私人债权,因为公共债权其实无所谓利率多少
我美国政府我要借5%、8%、6%我都可以借对吧,但私营部门要看收益的,所以他没有办法这样借
所以特别是在深吸的环境里面,就是利率比较高的这样环境,比方说在2020年到2022年
其实2022年到2023年这个周期,其实公共部门的债务一直在增加,比率在增加
其实你看那个DC的环境,20年到2022年的环境,其实公共部门的债务增加和私营部门的债务增加是差不多的,速度是差不多的
但是问题当你利率变高的时候,你的公共部门就会挤压私营部门,获得更多的债券和债券的比率
因为整个经济的增长,它本质上还是quadrox,信贷增长
中间当然有一些比方说钢杆率的问题,但跑掉这些钢杆的问题,基本上就是把它经济增长当成一个信贷增长
那你信贷增长就来自于私营部门和来自于公共部门,如果说公共部门获得的债务更多,那么它就会公共部门获得债务更多
那它的比率就是政府的力量就会更大,其实最终就是你政府的力量有多大,政府的融资在国家经济增长中间占多少比率
往往政府的比率,就奥斯丹利带,这是总的持有的债务,就奥斯丹利带
持有的比率越大呢,然后发债的比率越大呢,然后你往往就会变成更加无效
所以这是一个快乐的陷阱,就是当我每一块钱,就除了二二年,二二年可能有一次经济几亿几乎变零了吧,所以这个点又可以参考
但是如果你看二一年到二五年的话,整体的就是美国,你的信贷增加的时候
你的经济增长需要多少信贷来拉动,这个东西会越来越大,就是有点像细毒
所以细毒的过程你是要吸更多的毒,所以你要吸更多的东西,你才能够获得同样的快感一样的,就是你要拉动同样一块钱的几厘平
你需要的信贷增长是越来越大,这个事情的中国人有很明确的这个反馈,就是中国其实干
干信贷增加,然后干国家投入,这个东西比美国早很多,所以中国有更加切身的体会,那么
一旦你进入了快乐supermao,就是我们叫做进入了这个
信贷的大规模增加的时候,你有没有可能走回头路的,有很多人试图走过回头路,对吧,我们那个
这凭错了,是吧,我们搞过,中国就搞过什么去去去,那个供给色改革,然后搞过地方政府发展限制,没有用了
就你任何一个地方政府,你看他预算怎么能降下来,在中国,在全世界都是一样
因为这里面,这个权力是个好东西,就是从不管地方政府,或者是
集中化的权力是好东西,你越多的话,你能做事情越多,你也能说完权力,你也能够做各种各样的东西,你能够
有一点点腐败,所以在这里面呢,就是很难把政府的赤字给拨过来
就一般来说政府占用的资源越多,就是发展一样的,就是你
你发的债务越多,所以你会占领更多的政府,全国的这个资源
然后你会让整个经济变得更加无效,这是一个铁三角的规律,在中国也是
私营经济发展,比率越高的时候,经济越有货力,然后政府比率被迫再提高,因为它发展,它要带动经济发展
它能够承受更高的利息,然后它有更好的,甚至有的时候在中国,不对等的那个利率
它的利率可能还更低,但是在这个环境里面,它能够占用更多的经济资源的时候
它国家的整体的效率一定是下降,这个是好语问
所以这个两个才是快乐supernova真正的问题,就是债券
我们叫做阿达予基的真正的问题,美国还没走到这一步
就是说你一旦你走到这一步以后,你会发现这个国家有点像英国
就是英国现在那个债务已经开始比政府支付,比经济增长要Normal GDP
就是民意GDP要高了,所以这个环境里面政府会获得越来越大权力,因为这里面不光是一个经济的问题
这个后面还有政治的问题,就是政府会获得越来越大的权力,然后去比较说干移民复平
然后去在什么这个故意念改革,这种鸟是在美国很少发展出来
即使民主党政府都还没能干出来,但是在欧洲很多国家已经开始了
所以这个会有很多的政治的影响,那么在这个过程中间呢,要把这个clock,要把这个时钟搬回去
其实要搬到什么时候,要搬回到2008年
2008年以后,其实这个也是Tabin Wash一直在说,他说到包括我要做qt,我要把利率变低
然后其实是不希望这个阿达玉际或者是不希望政府融资的比率一直在提高的过程中间
损害私营部门的这个社会资源,然后损害整个社会的效率
但这个事情的,我不觉得他们会成功,因为我刚讲政府的债它本质就是一个系统
系统你是没有见人能够记得掉
因为钱和权都是个好东西,这个东西很难记得掉
那么原来用什么东西在控制这个阿赫际呢,就是控制这个利润,就是说阿不能大预计
那么什么东西在控制这个利润,其实一旦你国家要不停的发展的时候
你假设你正常情况不停的发展,没有一个中央正义,央行在那里控制利率的情况下,你的利率会一直往上跑
所以当Tabin Wash说到我要把利率还给市场,就它基本上这个意思,就是我不给fat dot,然后我不给
不给前瞻性的指引,然后我们完全按照通胀来,我要去控制通胀,然后其实本质上我也不想做QE,他不想做QE
然后我不想给于,就我不想去控制市场的长期利率,控制市场长期利率有不同的给法
比方说你给他一个指引,比方说两年的指引,或者是你给他一个QE,或者是日本搞的YCC,他都是一个控制长短利率
其实本质Kavin的意思,Kavin Wash的意思是我只控制短短的利率,然后我这个东西是跟着通胀来的,你们就看数据就好了
所以你不要来问我,我对长期利率是什么样的指引,或者长期利率怎么样,长期利率是一个市场决定的东西
所以市场交易出来,那08年期就市场交易出来,但是你如果放弃对于短端利率R的控制的话
那个会有什么结果呢,就是会有大量的发债,因为现在既存的情况和08年是不一样的
然后既存的情况就是美国有大量的债务要发行,你国家有大量的债务要发行
你可以看得到,其实在那个深吸这一轮以后,基本上我认为已经开始走路一个不归路
至少走到中国一三年、一四年之运,至少走到一三年、一四年
甚至更晚,中国已经完全是不归路走到桥另外一边去了,就把桥给烧了
因为你完全必须要不停地靠政府的支出,美国至少走到一三年、一四年
所以你把利率还给市场,就是你会有大量的发债,然后这个债务还在增加
你的需求端,你从哪里来,新的需求端呢,就是你当然今年你可以做银行的那个去检管
然后你把那个需求端带起来,但你是每一年持续的要给到市场新的需求端来解决他债务的问题
如果不解决他债务利率就会往上跑,所以这个也符合了,其实连处这个东西也符合了
有时候他的一个意图啊,就是说你国家的债务什么时候能够无限吗,不能无限
不能无限让市场来调解你,然后把利率给你搞高,那长端利率给你搞高
因为你本身短期利率 guidance,也就是能够发个20%吧,tbl能够发到20%
然后你要 outstanding 里面,就是你总的存量里面
然后你要发去,发到长端,发到五年,发到十年,你供需的问题就会让你利率上去
然后你利率上去就要控制一下你的这个花钱的节奏,所以这个是一个非常理想化的一个情况
但是实际的如果他这么做,他把他把这个R给放开,他把利率放开
其实我就是觉得长端利率会进,长债会进入一个长雄
就是比较长的雄市,那个利率会慢慢慢慢一直在往上跑
那个特别是五年到十年期的这些利率,因为五年到十年期的需求没有那么大
当然在今年看上去还可以,因为今年的其实是其实是银行在去监管
去监管的时候呢,你本身不放在那个balance 上,不放在那个
我们叫做 risk capital 就是那个风险资产上,本来是放在风险资产上的那些资产
被银行从风险资产里面拿出去了,所以就是国债,所以银行买国债
它是等于是可以钢杆随便买
那么大概我之前说过,就是大概增加4万5到5万亿的银行资产负责表啊,就是可增投的资产负责表
所以你在今年可能没有看到这么明显的反应,但是如果我们连处,这个看后面几期了,接下去有看
Kavin 接下去是不是这么干,就是如果是这么干下去的话,他理论上他是会持续的给到长端一个往上的推动力
就是利率往上的推动力,因为供应很大,就是会一直有供应
然后,原来是怎么去控制这个啊,就是YCC 包括QE,它其实控制利率嘛,控制利率其实就是硬钱
然后,控制利率是硬钱的,这个硬钱马上会造成空招,理论上来说
但是,未来让硬钱不造成动仗,所以美联储、欧洲央行行和所有人都在对金融端,对金融公司进行去钢杆
就是08年的钢杆,其实一直去到20年、25年,然后才去完
然后,这个过程中间其实,你把整个银行的钢杆率可能从30、35,看着更高
黎文报的时候35、40万,然后一直降到15,就把整个钢杆率降下来
所以,你可以这样认为,就变相的来说,其实YCC、日本的YCC、QE,他们做的事情都是一样的
就是在央行层面去剥夺了商业银行的资源
在政府层面,你发债,你是剥夺了民营企业的资源
就是,政府每进的一步都是人民的一大退步
这个在任何一个国家,任何一个成权都是,都是适用
所以,所以,你政府层面的发债,你占有了民营的资源
但是,你YCC和货币上面的发债,你是让银行去监管
那银行进行的监管,你是剥夺了金融本身的这个金融机构的这个资源
所以,他们是想把这个时钟剥过去
但是,时钟剥过去中间就要取决一个东西
就是,你的R增长是你的那个利率增长,你需要很难制作
因为你要发债,那你就必须要Growth,必须要经济增长
但是,现在经济增长这个东西呢,非常决定于AI的技术
非常决定于资本市场
这个你也能够理解了,就说白宫为什么,包括在这次伊朗事件
包括一直持续的,它对于股市门,或者对于资本市场,它这么在意
因为它已经堵上去了,它现在要做的经济改革
包括在利率层面,在联绩层面的经济改革
和你后面的,都取决于你的这个蓄水池
就取决于你这个Growth能不能增长起来
如果市场崩掉的话,你马上进入债务的上限
就是,进入一旦进入你的债务超巨型的时候,央行就会很明显的面临两个抉择
就是你要抉择选通账,还是你要抉择去控制上当利率
就是你要控制上当利率,你就把这个通账给放弃掉
也就是在现在在美国这种情况下,如果说你要控制上当利率,你要不放弃通账
你就必须金融继续监管,然后让银行的杠杆才降低
就欧洲干的这些事情,就是每一个政府权力大的国家,就往往就会淡出这些鸟试
然后让银行去监管,银行加监管,加各种各样监管,加各种各样合规
然后让你杠杆不能上去,不能做表外
然后搞各种各样扶贫,因为他搞各种各样移民扶贫
然后你要把这个钱给花出去,政府把钱花出去
然后搞各种各样的所谓的各种各样改革,什么供应链刚
这种鸟试基本上都是欧洲这些政府能够去做的
然后你在整个去负责这个责任的时候,你现在其实银行层面已经没有什么空间
可以继续去去港版的
所以你很有可能当你再去维护你的利率的时候
你要债务不增加,不爆发增加的话,那你的通脏就要上去
所以这个是它的dynamic,这是美联储现在的dynamic
也是一个现在在这个时点最后一个路线选择
就是你到底要走哪条路
所以你能够理解为什么包括,就我刚讲的白宫政府
包括他们这么在乎这个资本市场
其实资本市场扮演的是一个蓄水池的作用
中国刚刚开始融资搞那个大规模政府投入政府基建
然后政府借钱,然后挤压组
不挤压组,就是因为政府借钱借了多
你肯定民企借钱借了少
然后政府在经济中间占比才增加的时候
其实中国也有一个蓄水池
中国蓄水池就房地产
所以房地产让这个蓄水池让中国经济看上去增长比较快
所以它的这个growth会一直高于当时的利率
就是中国也是这样子
所以你这个游戏才能够玩下去
然后你的债才没有爆掉,然后你的债才没刀顶
但是大家都知道你的蓄水池是有底线的
你不可能无限制的往上搞
所以当你的债务最终政府的投入越来越大
政府的融资越来越大
然后挤压了越来越多的资源之后
你的效率不停地降低
那么你这个债务总是要保得
我们从其实14年15年
然后好几次就是想去做一些改革
然后把这个问题执着
但是其实也没执着
所以美国可能也在那个时点
他也想去做这样改革
只是说美国现在的这个growth取决于培案
取决于他觉得他可能有新生生产力
新制生产力
这个叫新制生产力
他们可能有他们的新制生产力
因为你长期的要把增长变大
你不光是要有蓄水池
就是财富小营
你是需要增增增加社会社会的效率
所以这个效率的增加就是寄托于培案
所以我们会看到整体他们这个
我个人的理解对于白宫的政策
对于联储的政策的理解
是联储其实是想变得更加市场化
就是不想走那个走中国
欧洲走过的路
然后或者日本走过的路
日本为什么这么多债
他还持续补充问题呢
我补充一下
因为日本的俄罗斯特别地
就是他当年的泡沫破掉以后
包括人口问题
所以导致他长期的通缩
他长期的通缩
他一方面在大量的发展
就是第一方面在YCC控制
然后一方面对所有的钢杆
再接近加钢杆
然后一方面经济又变得很差
经济增长
增长变低
他的利率又变得更低
利率低于经济增长要变成负的
所以他这样的一个跑下去以后
就把整个经济活力给变得没有了
所以我觉得GOP那边有一批的想法
可能是要逆其道而行之
我们不想走上这条路
因为我们刚刚走
就是他们走在前面没有很好
那三个走在前面的都没有很好
所以我们不想走这条路
我觉得是这样
但是不想走这条路
你的G就没有办法放弃
然后G没有办法放弃的
你对AI就很寄期往于AI
和寄期往于AI带来这次革命的效率
提高核弹
带来资本市场的蓄水
所以事不宜待
我对后面的资本市场风险
我觉得还是不小
然后我说一下
这个讲一下货币政策和利比奥
然后我讲一下对后面几个
hyperscale的烈期的预期
我觉得每年处基本上是这样子
就是说几个hyperscale主要看两方面
就一个我们上次讲说看Kapex
看你下年明年投入多少
然后第二个看AI
我是感觉在七月份这次业绩的时候
AI的讨论会原来的多
就是两方面的AI
一方面是说当谷歌这种公司
我投入这么多Kapex
然后我收入多少钱
然后收入这些钱
我是不是可以支持我的Kapex
然后我收入来至于谁
我收入谷歌
谷歌是一个完全可以自己内循环的公司
因为他的模型也是他自己的
所以他账会被看得更加清楚
其他几家
因为他的收入来源是来于
Infovic OpenAI那两家模型公司
所以他模型公司的账是分开的
模型公司也没有上市
但基本上这样大家都知道
他每个月要沟通了
基本上你AR增长多少都知道
所以你会看你的增长AR
是不是justifiable
就是你不光是看我给语音
我给酸力中心提供了多少钱
我也要看我前面的模型公司的收入
是不是可以被justifiable
所以这个我觉得是第一个
谷歌是重在去
因为他自己会被看透
前后端都会被看透
然后第二是
RY的review是在于很多公司
在继续拥抱AR的时候
对于成本投入的一个利益
因为现在我看下去
像如果用Infovic这些模型的话
成本就很高
就我自己用的话
可能一天一千多块钱
而且我一天一千块钱美金
一天一千美金
我还是只用于来省个代码
我都没感应他写代
就引导成本
所以就我上次讲过一个事情
就是AI最终是智商
智力是属于有钱的人
所以智力属于有钱的人
你一定是毛利最高的地方
你会去用这些模型
就用最好的模型
毛利更低的地方
可能会进入一个成本审核的review
这个成本审核的一些公司
如果是对于成本审核
还是考虑我到底花多少钱
我聊天比方说上次是
我说等讯好像就已经降低了
降低的那个每个人用的扣大了
对吧
然后越来越多这样的公司
干这种事情的话
但美国公司看上去
IT支出成本很高
IT的IT
它IT可可用费用很多
但是你最终可用费用
挤不上模型的这个增速
所以当有公司或者一些公司
一起发出这种声音的时候
那会影响到大家
对第一个ROI的这个考虑
就是我投资收益的考虑
那么投资收益的考虑
最终就回到了CAPEX
这两个问题有什么两个连在一起的
因为今年你的CAPEX
是要做几千七百七千七百亿吗
你明年给出的概念到底是给多少
这个和ROI是一起看
所以我是觉得
因为在7月份年中的时候
你其实是要去去那个回
不是回顾
要预先预要去展望
明年的CAPEX和ROI
这个问题就纳入讨论了
因为在年初的时候
我们讲那个今年的
佛沃的PE基本上讲到二七年年底
二七年到底怎么做CAPEX
其实不大清晰的
二六年是一个清晰的途径
但是在二六年年中的时候
二七年就需要有个清晰的途径
大家要展望二八年
然后在这个时候
也会有人问到这个问题
你比较说明年是一万亿
现在没有人讨论二八年是多少
那二八年一点五万亿吗
二八年一点五万你钱哪里来的
就是你的钱哪来
所以你当你开一个公司估值
现在大部分的公司的估值
都已经估到二八年去了
就是二八年的给了二八年的佛沃的
那你二八年的钱哪来的问题
很快也会有人问
那最简单的就是模型公司
然后模型公司收入
开始能够Chestify这些
这些CAPEX
但但我觉得很难
那至少很难一错而就
就是很难
一帆风顺就很难一帆风顺
就中间一定会有
一定会有来回的过程
所以这两个是要讨论的讨论点
所以我觉得其实在二季度的业绩的时候
特别是在几个大名厂的业绩的时候
风险是大于手艺的
就它能够给到你正面的回馈
我想很难
包特别是五个
谷歌模型还不太起
今年
谷歌问题我好像去年就讲
就是我去年就说
它包括TPU
TPU是便宜
那那个PerformanceWatts
是远远不如MV的卡的
那它凭什么
它的模型可以一直领先
我从来就没觉得它模型能一直领先
对吧
所以你回头看谷歌的问题
就是我觉得谷歌当然是很伟大的公司
就是它要是很长期看是没有问题
但是它进入了他们
包括谷歌
包括微软
包括这些互联网巨头
进入他们从来没有过的一个环境
就是我积累了十几年的财富
我收割全世界十几年的财富
今天要去投到AI
然后中间可能还有30%
留到美国以外去
留到韩国去
留到韩国台湾去了
百分之几留到中国很少
百分之有些光不坏的中国
所以这个预期是非常难给的
就是你要挣挣好好
要割捩
要非常挣挣好好
你要模型的模型的收入
非常好
然后给出的tapax预期不高也不低
因为你tapax预期太高的话
市场一定会崩盘
就是市场会觉得你没有钱
就我刚刚问的问题
如果你个人更高
明年给1.1万亿
那后年1.6万亿吗
那1.6万亿的钱哪里来的现金
你前面俩模型公司还融资
你要找我们融多少钱市场
所以这个问题
你美国GDP才多少
你哪里的融资那么多钱
所以这个问题
如果你是把tapax弄的很高
那是必然要出爆掉的
然后如果你tapax弄的低了
大家马上对半岛第一轮赏
就是觉得我现在给你二百年
故事给太高了
因为我们可以看过去几个月
整个市场当然风气很好了
很强
就我讲的它有一个DP的泡沫的那种特点
就是一旦一下跌就人不超顶
那个大家觉得看了二百年盈利缺货
去到底
我只要是细风看一个行业一个公司
我根本就根本就两点一种就冲上去的
对
然后但是你要往
但是一旦上面有个风险
比方说cpu 迭累了
然后800幅迭累了
或变慢了
或者我我本来几年就是明年迭发
然后他都觉得今年迭发
然后你稍微
稍微有一点点风吹草腾
就会就会跌很多
这个就说明市场的其实对于这个
开拍四调整端是预期是没有弹性
所以你如果开拍四往下调整
它会非常大的风险
然后网上调整
会非常大的风险
所以你得正正好好
所以我是觉得七月份的这个
七月份的这个不太容易给
七月份整个整个
特别是四大云城开拍四大云给
然后讲到其他公司的原因
其他公司的原因统统没有问题
有半导体
因为跟着他们后面统统没有问题
所以半导体全部缺货
现在已经到了你到那个先进之城
到了那个成熟之城
我想讲过成熟之城现在都全部缺货
就是基本上你们可以认为
现在如果没有需求的公司
这公司半导体公司
它不大应该存在
这公司应该直接死掉
就新的技术
像Serebus这种新的技术
都是LBI的单独拿过来
就是去决于你的能拿多少供应
所以你会在整个行业
就不我就简单说
就这因为太多公司我说过了
但简单来说的话
基本上你会看到成GPU
CPU存储光不快
然后什么MLCC就全缺货
全部全部不会太长
业绩全部比的
所以这个是确实半导体大作企
但是小心上面的方向
上面才是我们真正关注的
所以关注的是云长的业绩
你不用去关注个股
个股都没事
他们的业绩都很好
好
然后我今天大致讲讲一下
宏观的宏观我对利率的一强
就是我相反
我是觉得利率是一个
以前说西西弗斯在推石头
利率是要一直往上跑
因为发债量一直在增加
特别是当你不去控制长短利率的时候
他会一直一直这样跑
然后宏观那个短期里面AI
就我觉得这个风险就是在云厂上
云厂上钱哪里来这个问题
好吧
我今天要不先这样
然后看看大家有什么问题
我可以Q&A一下